today we'll be explaining all members of
The Mysterious d-clan there is a total
of 10 insanely strong members and will
cover all of them starting with Monkey D
GARP all right Andrew Rosanna please
stop the dramatic music all right that's
better Monkey D GARP is a father of
dragon and grandfather of Luffy he was
the one who initially trained Luffy as a
child before he even embarked on his
journey to become king of pirates you
could say that he had a pretty
unorthodox Training Method as he would
frequently throw Luffy into valleys
leave him in dangerous forests and even
tie him to balloons over high altitudes
you know at times I'm not sure if he
actually tried to train Luffy or just
straight up kill him GARP is loud
energetic cheerful and overall acts
similar to Luffy but don't let his
childish personality fool you he is
without a doubt one of the strongest
fighters in the entire 1p series
although he's almost 80 years old after
the time skip GARP still possesses an
incredibly high amount of physical
strength he's able to throw iron
cannonballs as if they were baseballs in
both carry and throw a gigantic ball
many times bigger than the Thousand
Sunny GARP also has a monstrous punching
ability at his disposal which led him to
being called GARP the fist he's also
known as the hero of the Marines and as
a man who quartered and fought Roger on
multiple occasions with both of them
nearly killing each other furthermore he
proved how knowledgeable he is about
combat as he trained both Luffy and Ace
both of whom became incredibly strong
Pirates so you may be wondering why
someone as powerful as GARP is only a
vice admiral well you see he was
actually offered to be promoted to
Admiral a bunch of times but he refused
every single one of them since he didn't
want to serve directly under Celestial
dragons at the end of each character
we'll also compare his strength to other
d-clan members and I can say with
confidence that GARP is an easy s-tier
since you're watching this video you're
obviously a one-piece fan but do you
like the attack on Titan II did you ever
want to play a game where you can be
your favorite aot character in battle
Titans but you're in luck since the
sponsor of today's video life after is
collabing with aot to bring you guys
just that life after is a doomsday
Survival game where you can explore the
world collect resources and battle
enemies the most interesting about life
after is that you can cooperate with
other players and build camps together
which makes a pretty unique playing
experience it's no secret that I'm a
huge aot fan I mean the name of this
channel is literally jagerists so I
personally can't wait for their
Crossover with Attack on Titan in this
crossover the Armored Titan is leading
the army of zombies to destroy human
camps you'll have to team up with other
survivors in order to fight the Titans
and defend your camp in addition to
outfits of Aaron Mikasa Levi and Krista
there will also be three original aot
themed outfits for your pet and don't
worry the most important aot item the
vertical maneuvering equipment is also
in the game and it'll take the air
combat experience up a notch try using
it while wearing one of the crossover
outfits it looks so cool download life
after Now using my link in the
description or by scanning my QR code
and if you log in for a few consecutive
days you can get free rewards like
Titan's giant balloon pendant and free
crossover hoodies anyway let's continue
the list with the legendary mysterious
by
was the captain of rocks Pirates and one
of the most fearsome pirates in the
history of the one-piece World although
Rock's individual strength and abilities
were never shown he was well known for
leading a crew of extremely dangerous
Pirates indicating that he was an
extremely powerful and charismatic
individual and most likely the strongest
person of his time many of his crew
members would go on to make big names
for themselves Edward Newgate Charlotte
lindlin and kaido even became Emperors
of the new world zedek was considered to
be the most formidable rival of the
pirate king Goldie Roger even more so
the Whitebeard would come to be he was
so fearsome he took both Roger and
Monkey D GARP working together to
finally defeat him Rock's defeat was
also what caused Garb to become a legend
and to be known as the hero of the
Marines showing just how much of a
threat the world government considered
rocks to be kaido who's known as the
world's strongest creature seems to put
zebik in the same Elite Class with a
very small number of pirates including
the likes of Goldie Rogers and Shanks
aside from raw Strang Rock seems to be
very intelligent and knowledgeable man
as he studied many different sub objects
and was able to unravel many of the
world government secrets after he was
defeated the world government completely
erased his name from history these are
only two of the 10 characters I'm
covering today and if you stick till the
end I'll share a fun fact about Goldie
Roger that I guarantee you don't know
number eight Goldie Roger Roger was
famed as the man who did what no one
thought possible he conquered the grand
line in a master vast Fortune afterwards
knowing that he would soon die from an
incurable disease Roger disbanded his
crew before turning himself in the world
government intended to have Roger
publicly executed to discourage piracy
but it didn't really go like that just
as he was about to be executed Roger
told everyone that he hid everything he
gathered at one place and anyone who can
find it can keep it as such Rogers
single-handedly started the Golden Age
of piracy as all Pirates around the
world started searching for his treasure
Roger had the highest recorded bounty in
history over 5 billion 500 million
bellies which puts him above all
currently strongest pirates in the world
what's even more impressive is that
Roger didn't even possess devil fruit
abilities he achieved everything using
only his physical strength in hockey
Roger had many rivals one of whom was
Whitebeard the World's Strongest Man Who
Roger battled many times without a clear
winner other examples of Roger's
strength include fighting on equal
ground with Shiki who commanded the
largest pirate Fleet of his time and
single-handedly defeating the armies of
several countries Roger was also one of
the most skilled hockey users and he
would often fight by imbuing his saber
with hockey this allowed him to evenly
Clash against whitebeard's hockey
infused Monaco mangiri although the
battle between him and Whitebeard ended
in a tie he managed to defeat Kazuki
Odin in insanely strong hockey user with
a single attack furthermore he could
also utilize the advanced application of
emitting buso Shoku haki out from his
blade allowing him to attack opponents
without making physical contact number
7. harkus D Rouge parcus D Rouge was
Ace's mother and the lover of Roger very
little is known of rouge as a character
but she seemed to be very kind and a
loving person she also displayed the
typical traits of those who carry the
will of D such as a strong will and
smiling shortly before death she held
her pregnancy for 20 months to do sheer
willpower in order to deceive the world
of Ace's connection to the pirate king
when the child was finally born Rouge
held him in her arms and named him gold
dies however as the results of dragging
out her pregnancy for so long she died
immediately after giving birth since she
sacrificed her life in order to save her
child from the world government Ace
claimed that he owed her a dead and took
Portuguese as his surname she's also the
first and so far only known female to
have the initial D appear in her name
number six Jaguar D Saul Saul was a big
and friendly giant who was so much shy
and timid at some point in his life he
became a marine and eventually made it
to the rank of vice admiral it said that
he traveled in the grand line although
not much is known about his adventures
while he was loyal to the Marines he
questioned their orders multiple times
which shows that he followed moral
Justice over the code of absolute
Justice in the end it was this moral
judgment that led him to betraying them
as Saul could not see why the Marines
would need to slaughter an entire clan
of mere archaeologists who had no
Fighting Chance against them being a
giant he possessed almost on unbeatable
strength he could easily lift a buster
call Ship up out of the water and slam
it back down his durability was immense
as well easily brushing off the
explosions from direct Cannonball hits
even though he didn't possess devil
fruit Powers he wasn't scared of the
ones that did even stated that he was
somewhat jealous of their incredible
abilities he died while protecting young
Robin from the Buster call that
destroyed Ohara being frozen to death by
fellow vice admiral kuzan only five more
characters are left and it only gets
better from here as the next decline
member is the biggest enemy of the world
government Monkey D Dragon Monkey D
Dragon also known as the world's worst
criminal is the infamous supreme
commander of the Revolutionary Army
dragon is dedicated to dismantling the
world government and its corrupt
nobility system that allows Nobles to
oppress lower-class citizens as they
please he's usually very serious and
calculated always keeping an eye for
what's happening in the world and
educating his subordinates about
relevant objects and events while his
individual combat abilities are mostly
unknown he's able to command extremely
powerful Army officials like Sabo and
the 5 commanders who have all been shown
defeating notable Pirates and Marines in
the grand line Oda has also kept
dragon's Bounty a secret for the
entirety of the series but it's pretty
obvious that due to the threat he poses
to the world government his Benny will
most likely be the highest if not the
highest in the show Dragon was also able
to effortlessly stop smoker when he
tried to kill Luffy and what's even more
interesting is that despite dragon's
great criminal status smoker didn't even
try to apprehend him this is possibly
because he knew it would be pointless as
dragon is way stronger than him
additionally ivankov noted that Luffy's
inhuman will to live made sense for a
son of dragon indicating that he has a
similar level of tenacity while at the
Goa Kingdom in Logan Town Thunder and
strong blasts of wind have occurred in
close proximity to Dragon which have
helped him accomplish his objectives in
both places it's still unconfirmed if
Dragon actually made these weather
changes himself but in my opinion he
definitely did this would also mean that
dragon is some kind of devil fruit that
allows him to control weather and create
natural disasters number four Marshall D
teach while he was younger teach started
out his pirate careers is an apprentice
of the Whitebeard Pirates and eventually
became a member of the crew's second
division however he defected after
murdering thatch the fourth division
commander in order to steal the yummy
yummy Nomi prior to the two-year time
skip he briefly held a position among
the seven Warlords of the sea after
defeating and handing Ace over to the
Marines however after returning from
inpel down with level 6 prisoners and
strengthening his crew he resigned from
his position at some point in his life
teach fought Shanks and gave him the
scar on his left eye with Shanks
admitting that the injury did not occur
because of carelessness their battle led
Shanks to recognize Teach as an
extremely dangerous Menace his actions
resulted in him being considered a part
of the worst generation along with the
11 supernovas during the summit War he
murdered Whitebeard and stole his
guragura nominee Powers he also defeated
the Whitebeard Pirates during the time
Skip and took the majority of their
former territory this resulted in him
becoming one of the four Emperors with
the island of hachimosu acting as his
base of operations he has a bounty of 3
billion 968 million 500 000 bellies
which is currently surpassed only by
Shanks the before we cover the man who
will certainly bring a massive change to
the world and completely change the
course of history we still have two more
D's to cover and the next one is La La
was born in the country of flevens in
the North Blue the residents of flevens
had a disease which significantly
shortened their lifespan since the
neighboring kingdoms believe that
diseases were contagious lost country
was in constant war with them during
this war the extermination crew shot his
parents and the hospital was burned
while his little sister was still inside
having lost everything law became
omnicidal and wanted to destroy as much
of the world as he could before dying
because of this while he was still young
he went to doflamingo in order to join
the future warlord of the Seas crew
doflamingo accepted him and while part
of the Don Quixote Pirates he learned
Marksmanship from Gladius martial arts
from laoji and swordsmanship from
Diamante doflamingo hoped to eventually
find a cure for Law and raise him into
being his next right-hand man during the
time skip Law's batting increased to 440
million bellies before it was frozen due
to his induction into the seven Warlords
of the sea however after having his
title revoked during the events of the
dresserosa arc laspani was reinstated
and raised a 500 million bellies
eventually it would be raised to 3
billion bellies for his role in taking
down big mom one of the four Emperors
alongside kid and wano but ate the
opiobe Nomi a paramecia type devil fruit
which allows him to create a sphere of
light blue aura inside which he can
manipulate the fabric of space you can
manifest cisora over a very wide area
however he cannot move it once placed he
would instead have to dismiss the sphere
and create a new one in a different
location also lost Powers directly take
a toll on his stamina which is very
unusual for devil fruit Powers why is
one of the straw Hat's most important
Ally as he helped them many times and
even saved Luffy's life at the end of
the Marine Fort art number two porque
the Ace Ace was the biological son of
the pirate king Goldie Roger and porgas
de Rouge as well as sworn brother of
Luffy and Sabo hunted by the world
government for his lineage Ace was
eventually captured and sentenced to
death this resulted in the summit war of
marineford an all-out Clash of powers
whitebeard's forces against the Marines
and seven Warlords okay this all sounds
interesting but let's back it up a bit
how did it all start well firstly as a
favorite of Roger GARP adopted Ace Roger
wanted to give him a life free of
prejudice of being born from a family of
pirates GARP promised to make fine
Marines out of Ace and Luffy so you can
imagine how Furious he was when both
brothers became Pirates Ace even became
strong enough that at one point he
received an invitation to join the seven
Warlords of the sea however he refused
the offer which led to his Bounty being
raised over 100 million bellies and
attracted even more attention to him
across the new world Ace managed to
defeat Doma a notorious New World pirate
and his pirate crew all on his own which
is what got him recommended to his
current post is whitebeard's Pirates
second division Commander his overall
reputation and abilities had quickly
earned him a bounty of 550 million
bellies when Blackbeard defeated in
capture days teach was immediately
granted the position as one of the seven
Warlords of the sea further showing how
badly the government wanted Ace Ace 8
the metamera Nomi a logia type devil
fruit that allowed him to create control
and transform his body into fire he was
able to unleash massive amounts of fire
for large-scale damage as well as
utilize small Precision attacks his
signature attack was transforming his
fist into firing setting it forward as
it greatly increased in size earning him
the name fire Fist Ace it was even said
that his attack had the power to
annihilate entire cities despite his
immense power Ace was eventually killed
during the summit War while trying to
save Luffy from Admiral akinu don't
worry guys I didn't forget about the fun
fact I promised I'll tell you exactly
what it is as soon as we cover the last
character on the list the straw Hat's
Captain Monkey D Luffy Luffy was born in
fruscia Village to Monkey D dragon and
an unknown woman when Luffy was six red
hair Pirates stationed themselves in
fuchsia Village while they were there
their sniper yasop frequently told Luffy
that he had a son his age named usop the
same usop that would later join Luffy's
crew and become his sniper Luffy
initially tried to join the red hair
Pirates and after they'd been in the
village for nearly a year he stabbed
himself under his left eye to prove he
was tough enough to be a pirate it it
has the scar even to this day Luffy
would accidentally eat the gummagumma
know me fruit and eventually embark on a
journey to become king of pirates one of
Luffy's greatest qualities is that he
can become insanely more powerful in an
unthinkably short amount of time to the
amazement and disbelief of many Luffy is
continuously defeated people who are
renowned throughout the Seas for their
Incredible strength and skill Luffy's
Improvement can easily be observed in
his battle at Don Quixote though
Flamingo whom he managed to defeat after
furthering developing his gear
techniques he also took out a member of
the Marines giant Squad with a single
Gear 3 punch and defeated the powerful
giant hadruden with a single Gear 2
punch to the face not long after he
started his journey he earned a bounty
of 30 million bellies for defeating
buggy Don Krieg and arlung this bounty
was later raised to a hundred million
bellies after he defeated one of the
seven Warlords crocodile his bunny was
eventually updated to 3 billion bellies
for various actions like declaring war
against the world government
participating in Summit War defeating
big bombs sweet commanders and becoming
an emperor of the new world during the
radon onigashima Luffy's recently
heightened Mastery of advanced busashoku
and Hao Shoku haki allowed him to fight
on par with kaido although he was losing
the battle after Awakening his devil
fruit or as he calls it year 5 he
managed to finally defeat one of the
strongest pirates in the world the true
name of Luffy's fruit is hilohito no me
model Nika a mythical Zone type devil
fruit that allows its user to transform
into the sun god ninka this fruit is
possibly the most dangerous devil fruit
in the entire series as the world
government did everything in its power
to acquire it and even after 800 years
of trying they were unable to find it
afterwards they renamed it to gomagomu
fruit in order to hide its true power
while using this fruit Luffy's Powers
seemingly only limited by his
imagination and he can in theory do
anything he wants as long as he can
imagine it this power is also referred
to as the most ridiculous power in the
world alright finally it's time to share
a fun fact that I was talking about you
see on one occasion relay said that
Roger liked to do everything in a Flash
way and this is exactly why buggy uses
the word flashy all the time and tries
to do everything in the flashiest way
possible he's just trying to be more
like his former Captain click on this
video where we covered all 11 mythical
zones in one piece what are you waiting
for click it